split Time same direction if you have
any experience with POI whatsoever
you've played around with it you know
how useful it is and you also know how
difficult it is to train especially when
we start getting into the realm of
things like flowers so is there a cheat
code is there a way for getting down
split Time same direction that is going
to be a little bit more smooth than what
we usually do well I have a couple
exercises I want to show you today that
might help you out in that regard
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to guide you through
that tricky world of split time Same
Direction with a really helpful exercise
that's going to help you untangle a
whole bunch of different poy tricks in
the process but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys pyroar
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission all right
so I think it's probably uncontroversial
to say that split Time same direction is
the most useful timing and Direction
mode for POI when it comes to coming up
with stuff that is going to be
impressive to an audience we do
isolations in Split Time same direction
usually our three beat weaves are in
Split Time same direction and even when
we graduate to doing things like anti-
spin flowers we're still working in
Split Time same direction a lot of the
time or at least the version of it that
we're most used to thinking of is
definitely in Split Time same direction
and also this creates a problem for us
because we have to get down split Time
same direction in all these different
locations around our body in order to
accomplish these tricks now earlier
today I had a really great session with
one of my private lesson students and it
specifically revolved around trying to
keep split Time same direction stable as
we are opening up into broad shapes and
it helped me realize that one part of
getting down split time is just getting
the timing down that whole one 12 one2
thing but also managing to work in such
a way that you can keep that timing
going even as your arms spread far apart
because of course this is a basic
building block for getting things down
like our flowers as well as our linear
isolations and it turned out that there
was a really simple exercise that I
could give her to help her improve in
this regard so let's take a look at what
that is so this is going to start off
with you performing a little buzs saw
with your POI and it really doesn't
matter if it's a forwards or reverse buz
saw that's up to you but you're just
going to keep those po Bo spinning
between your arms like so and what
you're going to do is you're going to
practice opening up with one arm
creating a really big circle and then
coming back around to join that buzs saw
once again if you look at this from dead
on what I'm doing is I'm reaching out
and around and coming back in I'm
switching my hand to uh spinning the POI
out in wheel plane on my side and then
bringing it back around into buzs saww
plane so each hand individually starts
in buzs saww switches to wheel and then
comes back into buz saww like so you can
think of it as basically being kind of
like uh performing a 2B weave here where
my hand is going big on one side and it
staying small on the other side and I
want to practice this with each hand
individually so more than likely if
you're trying this exercise out for the
first time you're going to discover that
you're going to get in either extra
beats with the hand that's going big or
you're just going to lose your timing
entirely as you go through it why is
that so the reason here comes down to
something that I like to refer to as
beat control and it's a really really
essential element when we want to be
able to keep our timing and Direction
consistent when we're going between big
and small namely we have to make choices
about when we complete a POI beat and
when we don't so as we're going around
here there's two things that have to
happen in order to make this exercise
successful the first is that whichever
hand is going big is going to have to
move around in that big circle a little
bit faster than it probably wants to and
the hand that's staying small is going
to have to slow down its movement just a
little bit in fact if you take a really
quick look you're going to see that I'm
changing the speed of the PO that stays
in buz saww just a little bit as I'm
going around with the hand that's going
big like so it's the difference between
one 2 three beats versus 1 2 3 1 2 3
notice how the uh Tempo changes just a
little bit there so your first order of
business is to see if you can keep your
split Time same direction stable as you
go back and forth between going big and
going small like so if uh you want to
just hang out here for a few beats
before you go big and then hang out for
a few beats before you go big that's
totally fine but ultimately you want to
be able to switch back and forth between
which hand is going big and which is
staying small like so and keep your
timing and Direction consistent
throughout the entire move but wait he
says there's more because if we take
this exercise to its logical conclusion
we wind up coming up with something that
I like to refer to as a flower sweep
it's this right here and it involves
sweeping one hand past the other as they
perform flowers so let's work our way up
to it okay so the piece of this that we
already know is we start in a buz saww
we reach out big we reach out big yes
well we can also pause in the middle of
reaching out big and kind of splay
ourselves out here in wall playe with
our two po spinning split Time same
direction which being able to maintain
this in and of itself is a good exercise
for us to maintain too so once we've
opened up I can then bring my right hand
around boom to meet up with my left hand
and now I'm doing a little reverse buz
saww over here on my left hand side and
then right hand goes big and we pause
with both of the PO in Split Time same
direction once again and then left T
goes big to join back up with the right
so you could practice doing say like
three beats in each spot 3 2 1 3 2 1 3 2
1 3 2 1 to finish things off but you
want to go through each of these four
positions over to the right spread open
over to the left and spread open once
again and of course you can work your
way down to just doing one two one two
one 2 one 2 and one two beats in each
spot and when that gets to feel
comfortable we just do one one one one
one one one one as we take ourselves all
the way around the ultimate step is just
to not even bother to stop as we sweep
from side to side have that left hand
out and we sweep the right hand around
then we sweep the left hand around sweep
the right hand around sweep the left
hand around and look at that we have
arrived at our flower sweep pretty cool
huh and just as an added bonus one thing
that this helps you build up to is if
you can keep your hands together you
wind up in what's called a buzz soft
flower taking your hands around in
together same while the Poise spin in
Split Time same direction think of this
as kind of the ultimate expression of
this exercise and being able to keep
that split Time same direction going
solidly as your hands travel around with
it
but for today's purposes you can also
think that just going back and forth in
these flower sweeps is a good enough job
because at this point you've gotten a
really really good grasp on being able
to keep split Time same direction going
consistently going back and forth not
only across different sides of you but
also going back and forth between
Circles of different sizes with your
hands so go forth and I hope this helps
you with your split Time same direction
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like share comment
and subscribe to help other people find
it and to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much you
all rock and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one that is you like this
work that I do and you'd like to see
more of it easy way to do that head on
over to my patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor poy and sign up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to learn more about getting
down that 1212 timing that is absolutely
a to all split timing uh I will include
a link to a video I did teaching just
that concept I'll include it up on
screen as well as down in the
description thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace